[Music]
hello and welcome to the last session of
Android estimate or the ultimate session
I think which is called get animated my
name is Nick butcher I am a designer and
engineer here at Google my name is Doris
and I work on Android I talk with him
I'm responsible for Android animation
API and I'm you can ask for them working
on the design tools I'm always to do as
well as unconstraint layout John Hufford
working on constraint layout emotionally
out and design tools great let's add it
and so Android has always had an
animation api's and the number of API
zyre has grown as the system has grown
and become kind of more fully featured
there are a variety of different api's
for different situations that have been
added over the different API releases as
well as two and the new support
libraries like Android X but sometimes
we hear that the variety the range of
animation systems can be overwhelming
that you don't know which one to reach
for or which is the best for a certain
use case so our goal today is to really
give you a overview of the different
animation systems so you what they're
good for what they might not be good for
and give you the confidence to know
which to reach for when you need to
achieve something and we're gonna spend
a bit of extra time on the new hotness
that is motion they are today as well so
let's dive right in first up is androids
oldest and original animation API which
was Android view animation I would urge
you to kind of consider it deprecated
unfortunately it's not actually app
deprecated as I'll get to in a minute
but maybe just think of it in that way
so this like I say an old elder
animation API and was kind of runs in a
certain phase of the the view system so
everyone knows most views have like a
measure layout and a draw unfortunately
because the animations only run in the
draw pass and it means that we can't do
certain things like deferring
rendering when we don't need to and it
also leads to certain things where
because the animation is only applied in
the draw pass you don't know maybe the
lap the what it looks like it's
somewhere in your layout maybe you've
animated the button to a certain
position when you try and press it the
views bounds haven't actually changed it
only exists within the view system
there's drawing power system and so it
can lead to a bunch of different and
problems basically it's being
considerate and deprecated because it
has much much better and replacements it
belongs in a museum
[Laughter]
I'd say deprecated except there are
actually well one single use case I can
think of where you still have to use it
and that is when you were doing window
animations so when you're doing window
animations when a new activity launches
then this API only accepts this type of
window animation because existed from
API one but also because these windows
animations have to declaratively and
state all the information to perform the
animation the fact that it runs in the
draw part is useful because it
guarantees that the view is already
measured when you do this and that
allows it to define certain things like
here which she was seeing like a wide
delta animation which means 10% of the
the Y position so because it's already
definitely guaranteed to be measured and
this can be useful the only other place
you might need to use it is if you're
doing fragment transactions so here when
you set the animations to run a fragment
transaction you can supply this Android
view animation as an Arg but the API
also accepts the newer Android animator
so I urge you to kind of use the newer
one if you can so that was view
animations basically only really use it
for window animations or if you really
really have to if you need to rely on
that measured size part for a fragment
animation otherwise I think it's
deprecated next up
animator all right all right
so Nick has just talked about a view
animation now let's take a look at the
animator the new animator API that was
introduced in API 11 so the new animator
API is much more versatile than the view
animation because it allows you to
animate more than just view properties
you can essentially use it to animate
any arbitrary property on any object and
you can even just anomie any value not
necessarily associated with any property
at all using the value animator API and
since the introduction of the animator
we've built a bunch of higher-level
animation constructs on top of the
animator such as enemy director drawable
animate stateless drawable transition
and the default item in default item
animator in recycler view and people
always ask me between animation animator
which any machine character I use and
the answer is definitely the animator
API because it's just much more capable
an in this section we're gonna look at a
few um animators we're gonna look at
value animators where you can animate a
value and we're gonna look at object
animator which not only animates the
value but also automatically sets that
value on a property we're also gonna
look at any other sets and then we're
also gonna take a look at the view
property animator it is not an animator
but it's backed by a value animator
we'll talk about a little bit more about
that in a minute and then also we're
gonna look at property values holder
which you can use in conjunction with
value animator so here's an interesting
animation with a little chuckling man
and that can be achieved with an America
drawable which people talk about in the
next section or you can use louder you
for it but now let's look past that and
on top of this little man there's a
there are text being animated in and out
so in order to achieve that we can just
simply create a object animator to
animate the Alpha property of this view
pretty straightforward notice
how here I'm supplying us an Elfa string
and that is a bad idea
because when a property string being
being is being passed to the object
animator what we're gonna do is we have
to prefix a string with a set and get in
order to then use reflection to find the
setter and getter in the target objects
class and that's inherently more costly
what we recommend instead is using this
view the Alpha property object it is
introduced in API 14 along with a bunch
of other property objects for other view
properties what happens in this view dot
alpha is that whenever the animation
value gets updated the set value will be
called and then from there the set alpha
will be called on the view so that's one
level of indirection much more efficient
than reflection if we take a closer look
at this animation we can see that all no
text not only animate scene but also it
blows up so there are three things going
on its properties being animated the
Alpha skill X and skill Y um here's how
we can do that with property values
holder we can create three property
value holders one for each property and
then we can specify the start value and
the end value for the for each of the
property and once we have all these
property values holder is defined we can
then set these property values holder on
on the object animator so the then the
object animator can then drive the
change of the property values and one
caveat is when you use multiple property
value holders on one object animator you
are essentially animating all these
properties with the same interpolator
using the same duration on the same
target object but a lot of times we want
to animate scale X and skill-wise
simultaneously that's exactly what you
need and if you want to define that same
object in the emitter in XML with
probably values holders it looks pretty
straightforward now if you take a look
at the bottom of this this animation
there's that button fading again
after all the text animations have
finished to coordinate these different
animations together we can't just create
an animator set and then with the play
method it would return an animator set
builder and we want to play the fade in
after it to fade out so and then while
the text is fitting you also want to
blow it up so we're gonna play the fade
in with just scale animation and then we
want to play all the text animations
before the button phase in so that's
pretty straightforward API and powerful
too now we've seen how we can animate
various properties using property values
holders in conjunction with object
animator and if these properties that
you're animating it happened to be view
properties here's a more straightforward
way to animate them you can just call
view da enemy that would create a view
property animator and then they're a
bunch of messes for various properties
and then you set it end value for for
these properties and then optionally you
can you can set any interpolator and
start this is the syntax for view
property animator it doesn't get more
beautiful and concise than this and the
property is backed by a value animator
it's not an a mirror so you can't really
coordinated it with the other types of
any manners you
you also can't reverse it or secret it
or repeat it some people some people ask
me is view property animator as
efficient as object animator I can
assure you it's actually slightly more
efficient than the object animator the
reason for that is view property
animator has been optimized for
animating view properties and as a
result it infers that for all the people
properties that you're animating there's
only one one pass of you validation gets
triggered per frame whereas if you use
the object animator to animate various
properties then your each property
change it's going to trigger its own set
of validation pass you probably animator
is more for no fire-and-forget kind of
use case where you just star the
animation and just forget about it now
you might have seen this animation
before in the previous place did you
notice that there's a three little toss
animating at the end of the text and
she's these three little dots are not
really a property for the for the
textview so here we're gonna create a
value animator to animate the number of
thoughts we're gonna create a value of
integer type to enemy from zero to four
and once it gets to four then wrap
around and we start at zero because
there's a repeat count and with value
animator you almost always want to use
an update listener because value
animator is just gonna animate it on its
own it has no impact to anything outside
of it so here with with value with the
update listener we're gonna read the
value out of the value animator and that
I use it as the number of dots that
we'll want to show and and then we're
gonna have a span of all string from the
textview we're gonna set a span for the
we're gonna set a transparent foreground
color span on this tech um rather on the
task that shouldn't be showing and which
with each animation update we would
update that the number of does that
should be showing and then and then
correspondingly change the range to hide
the task that we want to not show so to
recap when should we use what kind of
animator object animator is kind of just
all-purpose animator that as long as you
have a property you own animate you can
use that value animator is for animating
a more custom customized kind of
animation where you want to enemy this
value and then you want to then use that
value to apply it to something else your
UI and the view property animator is
best used when you have multiple
view property is that you need to
animate simultaneously on the same view
and it's and because you can't really
coordinate this view property animator
with anything else is only good for the
fire-and-forget use case and then
probably values holder with probably
values holder you can define multiple
properties and and then any any made
them using an object animator the nice
thing about you probably values holder
compared to view property animator is
that it not only allows you to animate
multiple properties simultaneously
because it's really being set on the
object together you can coordinate that
or you know see so you can traverse so
it's more powerful and then animator
said when you have multiple animations
that you want to coordinate any meter
said would be a good choice thank you
very much next up we've got an animated
vector drawable so these are great for
doing a vector graphic animations like
these wonderful little icons you see in
the new google fit application and
animate affected drawable is actually
kind of a very thin wrapper around to
more powerful things it basically
connects together a vector drawable to
one or multiple object animators and
runs animations on them it has a very
kind of small and focused API it's
basically implements the animatable
interface which is basically just lets
you play pause and stop the animation so
you can get an animator vegetal or like
this and just call start um ABD is great
for like performance-critical and vector
graphic animation especially from new
gods where animated vector drawable was
re-implemented in native code and also
offloaded to the render thread which
means that even if you're yanking the UI
thread and you're not doing that right
and that your animation will keep on
playing but it also means that there's
just more rent of time on the thread for
you to do your code rather than running
the animation code so when to use an
animated vector all so when you need two
animated icons or animated vector
graphics when it needs to be this
fire-and-forget
because it has that simple API they just
start and stop and
can't seek through it you can't control
the progress for if you need to do
something like that then I urge you to
take a look at something like Lahti or
kiri KYR ie drawable and so it's really
good for anything which is like
performance critical and that was a VD
thank you now physics based animation
who doesn't love physics right this
animation is it's perfect for a highly
highly interactive in this case where
you have a loss of gestures going on and
you wanna you wanna then carry on that
momentum of the gesture into your UI to
create this sense of continuity and and
because when there are a lot of gestures
in flight you could then potentially
interrupt the existing ongoing animation
I'm sure you've seen any missions where
you want the animation to you want the
UI view to move from one location to the
other and then and then there's just her
from the users and as a result the
ending location would have changed and
in in this case if you use basic space
animation that would just simply change
some physics force and and then the as a
result the course question would be very
smooth and he also gives your app a more
realistic look so here I have an example
of just a little bubble with my cat's
picture on it and and it's you know
application overlay window so it's just
on top of other applications and in this
case that is the beautiful timely app my
goal is as I drag this little bubble
around it I wanted to follow my finger
and then when I let go it should rest on
either side of the screen so to achieve
this will obviously need to start with a
non touch listener and then we're gonna
use the velocity tracker to track the
movement and then when there's action
down when you to record a bunch of
positions in the subsequent movie events
where we're going to need to calculate
how much it has moved your finger has
moved since since that Downey went and
then update the the bubbles position
accordingly and then when when there's
action up that's where the interesting
base come in we're gonna calculate the
velocity from the velocity tracker and
then and then here for for
simplification simplification hope for
the for the demo we're just gonna say
when the velocity is greater than zero
we're gonna just move to the right side
of the screen otherwise left side now
now that we have the final position
where we want the bubble to rest on we
can create a spring animation to animate
that bubbles from ex prop that is a
custom property which I'll explain in
the next slide now we can before we
start the animation we'll also want to
set the start velocity and this is
critical to ensure that that transition
from gesture to the animation is
seamless so this is my custom property
and the the whole point of this custom
property is really just to associate the
animation value with the position of
that bubble whenever the animation value
changes we get this we get this set
value a call with we're then gonna set
that animation value on onto the layout
params X because that's because the view
is animating you know application
overlay window and then we're gonna have
have the window manager updating you
layout to reflect the change and then
similarly you can get value we're just
going to return the layout prime star X
that's me thank you next up is the
transitions API now the transitions are
really about looking at two different
lights two different layout states and
and saying what has changed between them
and how do I create an animation to
animate those changes so really you can
think of transitions as like a factory
for creating animators based on those
two inputs and while ago I might have to
up here and talked about how it's great
for doing things like this we can have
two different trend and transition
constraint sets and using transition
manager but I think like this use case
is actually better solved by a motion
layout so I wouldn't consider this a
good use anymore it did still have some
good things going for it
this is probably one of my absolute
favorite Android api's and transition
manager begin to late transition is like
deceptively simple but you call this and
then you make some changes to the view
hierarchy and magic happens and that
magic is exactly what we just talked
about it looks at those two different
states of the UI works out what's
changed creates an animator runs those
animations so simple there's also an
overload we can control those
transitions the other thing I really
love about transitions is that the what
it does to the shape of your code base
and so for example here's a change where
I moved a bunch of code out of the view
layer into transitions so you when
you're doing animations sometimes your
code can look a bit gnarly like this so
you're doing a lot of you look up stuff
adding pre-draw listeners and like
poking around to the view hierarchy and
by moving it to transitions we ended up
moving it to this much more kind of like
declarative composable architecture so
here I'm using some custom transition as
I wrote as well as compose with some of
the framework transitions in order to
achieve the same behavior but in this
more composable manner so yes you might
have to write some and some transitions
yourself like so here's one I have to
write to do a circular reveal but and
that code ends up being much more and I
don't know like nicer to work with and
much more focused and and I found it
like a really good change to the code
base so transitions when should you use
them but for me there's actually one
really strong use case which is shared
element transitions between activities
or fragments and so it's pretty much the
only thing you can use to achieve this
and as you go like super custom and so
that is the use case for transitions
there's actually two transitions going
on here there's the shared element which
is between the two activities we see
here and then once the details activity
launches and there's actually a window
content transition which is when the
window launches or when exits run this
and transition run these animations on
the content so when you see it come in
here when the view arrives the rest of
the content animates upwards that's a
window kind of transition so when should
you use transition API and two shared
elements for me is a really really
strong use case and window continent and
enter and exits and also if you're
really looking to like modular eyes and
compose your animation code then
transitions could be really helpful as
well as simple changes using that begin
delayed method so and yeah transitions
is definitely sort of a use case motion
layouts
all right so so far we've been talking a
lot about coding right and the nice
thing with coding is that it's super
powerful you can do a lot of things the
api's are really really complete on the
other hand it's also quite
time-consuming so you know taking my hat
on 100 to do design tools team what can
we do to help that really our goal is to
make you more productive you know let
you iterate faster experiment and make
your life easy already so we want to
make particularly for motion we want to
make the motion design a lot more
accessible so one one thing that we
introduced recently in constraint here
too is the helpers objects and in fact
helpers object is something that you've
been using if you use constructed before
that's what we use for guidelines for
bar years for this kind of tools that
are not really part of your view
hierarchy in the sense that they don't
show up on screen but they are here to
help you create those layouts so to
basically bring additional concepts to
make it easier and in 2.0 we expose them
completely so you can yourself create
helpers just by you know inheriting the
class and what's great is that it's a
way of encapsulating a behavior in code
and you know putting into a helper
we support the use of a personal read
studio so it's very easy to add widget
to those helpers to help us reference or
switch jets and you can you can think
about it as a way of tagging those with
jets with a specific behavior so in the
case of animation that's really nice
because you know you get the code you
had your helper built on top of this
code and we got all the wealth of the
Android animation API s and you can do
stuff like that right so for example
circular reveal you know pretty
well-known animation the only thing I
really needed to do here is to define
this piece of code and really what I'm
talking about
yeah okay what I can you know what I
only need to do here is this code in
that you see on the screen
I'm simply calling the view animation
utils create circular River so I'm not
reinventing the wheel here and
not coming up with my new new way of
doing secure reveal but that's the only
thing I need to do for my helper and
then in your layered file you only need
to declare that helper and specify the
IDS of the widgets you want to apply to
so it makes basically it's a lot easier
for you to package blocks of reusable
code and and and you know use them in
your application so going back to the
code stuff so the other way that we
thought about making your life easier
beyond you know letting you build those
reusable bricks is by moving to
decorative way for animation so you can
think about it as a specification for
motion and we interpret this
specification with a motion engine and
on top of that we are building a
graphical motion editor so it's
something we introduced at Google i/o we
are still working on it we decided to
focus those last few months on the
library side let's implement this motion
engine because we cannot want to make
sure that it's right for you and for
units but just a quick overview on the
chrome build it's coming along and
hopefully it will come soon
in Canary version of Android studio but
essentially we want to make sure that
the concept in the libraries are right
before kind of reducing the troll so
that's kind of like the overall approach
we have for helping you so the help
button one and and this motion
specification on the other the the thing
that's kind of nice if I look at this in
particular is that you can specify this
motion and will then take care of it you
don't really have to write code for it
it's it's really completely declarative
so the one way right now that we
implemented this motion spec is through
motion the ads so what is motion layout
it's it's a view group so one caveat is
that it means you can only animate the
children of that view group and it's a
subclass of construct yet so if you know
constantly art it's great you can
directly
use motion mayor 20 mature existing
constraint layouts on the flip side you
do have to know how to use constraint
layout but it does a lot so if we do
layout transitions we interpolate
properties as well we we have a really
powerful support for touch driven motion
so it's kind of like taking a little bit
of values areas of animation and
packaging it into a single place so
roughly speaking the only thing you have
to understand is we are animating
between two states we have a start state
and an end state and we just interpolate
between those two things so in addition
to basically supporting layout changes
so essentially if you have two versions
of the layout or to go from one to
another we also see bought you know
custom properties so for example if you
want to animate colors and we also
support the concept of keyframes and you
can think about keyframe as essentially
a modifier on that you know transform
between the start and the end so to kind
of summarize we motion layout it's it
allows you to think about your animation
your transition your motion as a
declaration you just specify what it
should do and we take care of it it
specifically is great when you want to
do fine tuned animation what we call
like this book and image bespoke motion
so where you know it's very specific
what you want to do it's about like
coordinating a bunch of witches together
in a very specific way and finally it's
really nice as well for the touch Riven
motion I don't think I need to make yeah
so I want to just kind of like show you
guys though a lot of things and it'll be
a little more visual from here on n so
this is where you want to create a
carefully crafted custom coordinated
yeah crazy-cool animation you can do
stuff like that so so how did it be do
that it's just two by two chains the
change into one chain and each letters
of U and then we use the stagger and a
color change in a custom attribute it's
fairly simple to build it took me a few
minutes at it it looks cool and that's
kind of what what this stuff is all
about so the first thing you can drive
our stuff with touch essentially it will
handle swipes if you flick it won't go
across quickly it understands the
velocity and and manages that the next
thing to understand is we're starting
from two constraint sets but we have
keyframes and in this case here I'm
starting with two constraint sets and
I'm not having any keyframes and you see
how it crosses right there right there
they overlap so what you do is you add
some key position
keyframes and you accelerate in the X
you finish the X part of the motion and
halfway through and that gives you a
kind of smooth you know use you can have
seen this it's your settings menu so the
more extreme end of what we can do with
with keyframes our key cycles and here
you can see a bunch of different kind of
effects that we can do essentially
anything that's oscillating it's shaking
or it's bouncing around you don't want
to actually go and build out complex
paths with keyframes this solves it and
then in alpha 2 we introduce time cycles
and and this is a kind of a crazy
animation you can do with it of course
this is way too over-the-top and please
don't use this in product
but so let's get into how to use it
right so thank you so first of all there
is a bunch of documentation that we
created so I'm going to pass quickly but
no please look at those articles there's
also a github with example so look at
that but one thing you you may ask
yourself is that okay this is all great
but how do I use that in my application
do I have to restart everything from
scratch
not quite now this is an example here
where you have a collapsible toolbar in
a coordinator layout and and to do these
kind of things with the normal
collapsible toolbar it's a bit annoying
you have to do it in code etc etc you
can simply use a motion layout instead
so you still use coordinate or a yacht
you don't really change anything else in
your code but the collapsible toolbar
becomes emotionally out and take all the
advantages of it similarly if you have a
drawer layout you don't have to use the
menu class you can use a code sorry
motion layout for it and do anything
crazy
same thing for view pager you can easily
plug motion layout into it the the last
example is interesting it's really looks
like coordinator layout but actually
this is pure motion layout and what's
nice about it is that it actually is two
motion layout nested and we have one for
the collapsible toolbar it's in fact
it's exactly the same one I used before
for the control layout example and it's
simply nested into an outer motion
layout and what's really nice is that in
order to specify or the this overall
screen gives I just need to create those
two states the Staton and you see that
in the end I bring up a fab and I simply
make the the the motion layout that's
for the toolbar a little smaller and
basically we take care of all of it
so to summarize for the current state
we're still working on the graphical
editor but for the library we released
it already at Google i/o and since then
we did an alpha 2 with a few more
properties
and you know even for its in alpha it's
actually built upon constantly at one
point when so it's actually pretty
stable and in fact because it's pretty
stable quite a few people has started to
build stuff with it and we'll go through
some examples just to give you a little
taste of what's what you can do with
motion layouts so I looked on the
Twitter a lot I checked
motion layout on Twitter all the time
and I I thought I would just share a few
interesting animations that people have
published so most of these you can
actually find in github
these people publish them as videos and
I've asked all of them to sort of show
them this guy has been doing quite a few
pieces of work with it it's kind of
interesting to see what he did here and
this one is particularly interesting by
the way you did not maybe notice in the
previous one there was a knock motion
which very nice something we had eaten
alpha2i
but in this particular example what's
nice is that it's it's kind of like a
view Pedro did it in motion layout but
he also added weight to drive it from
code and that's a very interesting you
know future avenue for us where we're
going to explore it's a little bit how
can you in code reuse some of this
previously defined behavior so another
one by him the interesting thing here
it's sort of mixing what is the normal
recycle of view and then sort of reveal
detailed view but it's an interesting
motion layout based animation between
the two of them and you notice that it's
super easy to come up with your own ways
of doing these kind of transitions you
don't you're not limited anymore
this guy implemented a a material design
animation spec but just using motion
layout and a custom view that he built
it was quite nice piece of work actually
one of the things I liked about this one
is it's so original I mean you see a
view pages
yeah okay this is like taking a whole
new twist on it or spin on it actually
but you can see it's original and that's
the beauty of abortion layout you can
sort of explore your own creativity or
your team's creativity with what they
they like and what they do this this one
is it is interesting because it's kind
of like a typical coordinator layout
stuff but you see it's transparent and
there's something special effects going
on with things fitting in as it's
collapsing it sort of produces a unique
you know custom view of the whole thing
and this is our Chris Bane's
and he did a very interesting one and
it's a whole app it's actually the all
the codes involved that is out there and
it is very custom so let's take a look a
little closer look at it so what's great
with it is this is the type of motion
that would be kind of fun going to build
purely by code because there's a lot of
subtle coordination across so many
elements the text is fading that poster
is actually rotating but actually
matching the young girl of the of the
cut so that's that's what we mean when
we when we are talking about bespoke
motion or very that fine-tune some
crafted motion this is the type of
example that we hope we don't create you
to build as a small sneak peek at what
we have in in alpha 3 it'll support
multiple states and and allow you to
interact with the multiple stay it's
purely from touch so this is one single
motion layout
but in fact a it's handling a transition
between three transition from a blank
page to swiping up the top at the bottom
to swiping a little bit to swiping more
it's all one page one motion layout and
it can produce a fairly sophisticated
Custer
view and I've sort of made it look like
a dialer yeah and this entire behavior
this touch behavior zero code from your
hand it's all declarative pretty awesome
cool so today well hopefully we've given
you a guided tour through this variety
of animation API so that does exist on
the platform and our goal was really to
make you more familiar with what they're
good at and what they're not so good at
so I'm gonna try and summarize that as a
takeaway for you here so that you are
confident in picking the right one at
the right time for complex coordinated
layout and especially for that nice
handoff between gesture and animation
then really really really do check out
motion layout next up if you need to
build interruptible and animations or
again do gesture to animation with like
that velocity tracking then look at the
physics layout and system if you need to
do shared element transitions or window
content transitions in your application
then transitions is the API for you and
if you need to do vector graphic
animations then check out animated
vector drawable if you need to do window
animations and only if you need to do
window animations then the original SDK
one view animation system should be use
it's your only choice and if you need to
animate properties of views and it's
supported by then look at the view
property animator if you need to do like
custom custom view animation or some
custom thing driven just by an animation
pulse then look at a value animator and
lastly like else use object animator
object animator is your go to default
for general purpose animation so
hopefully that's made a bit clearer so
next time you have to build something
you wouldn't be you know paralyzed by
choice of the different animation API s
and so thank you very much for joining
us and we'll be outside for questions or
contact us online thanks very much
[Music]